[Musique]
au sein du parc pénitentiaire français
le centre de détention des baumettes ne
fait pas partie des établissements les
plus difficiles mais c'est l'un des plus
vétustes et des plus sales bâtiment à
bâtiment b au moins 150 cellules propose
encore des conditions d'hygiène dans
notre temps c'est lui le à peu près dans
l'état où ils étaient contents ils ont
été construites en fin des années 30
sauf que quelques coups de peinture dont
l'équipement est vraiment ce qu'on peut
trouver deux de plus rudimentaires
c'est-à-dire y investit avec un robinet
d'eau froide au dessus du vc simplement
on n'a qu'un wc et alava beau enfin bon
partager un voilà il n'ya pas des ânes
cloisonnement cloisonnement mon bac pour
les cellules qui en bénéficient tant
mieux pour celle qu'il ne sent pas bon
ben c'est le système d un donc c'est la
ficelle reliés par ci par là avec le
murage faire en serviette de bain c'est
crade quoi les cafards les cafards la
poussière bon ça on va dire les détenus
dont cannes et à leur série je veux bien
mais les loyers ça fait pas tout pas les
cafards bon la promiscuité je sais pas
si vous avez vu les fenêtres sont toutes
les unes sur les autres dans le coteau
match pendant qu'alain qu'il a reçu sa
bassine pour i do avec l'eau pourrir et
l'âge est donc sacré
[Musique]